all you think is the [__] how can
this benefit me you [__] prick I
wasn't planning on making a video of the
day but you know sometimes you just
[__] have to unfortunately I'm in bed
six o'clock in the morning whatever it
is and I see this video
everyone's banging on about Logan Paul
this kid's a big [__] youtuber in
America just a douche bag joke why he's
not hurting anyone you know he's a
[__] idiot but who cares he's not
hurting anyone everyone's disgusted in a
mile thick boys made another [__] video
no it turns out he's done something
where after thought I'd make a video
voice I never thought I'd be saying this
on a video but the kid is one in over
forests in Japan because it's known for
suicides took the camera crew in there
with them lo and behold suicide forest
finds a [__] dead body now at this
point when you do that obviously you and
I regular [__] people say [__] dead
body yeah this is a serious moment in my
life I found a dead body put everything
down turn the cameras off don't put any
of the footage out you go back tell
someone about it then probably go about
your hotel room feel freaked out for the
rest of the day and maybe do a video a
day later explaining verbally not
showing anything saying what happened to
your audience but no didn't take that
approach the little [__] films
everything fills the dead body because
that's why I went in in the first place
my name is hoping to [__] find this
he was happy because that is a Bingle
moment yes we got one you know what I
mean why I'll see you [__] going in
there and filming do you not I mean yes
we got a dead body brilliant get the
[__] camera on it lets up but what
we'll do to caveat all of this because
we're exploiting someone and putting
them out there from video views and all
of that you don't tell me I didn't
monetize you knew this was gonna go
[__] viral and that instantly
increases who you are everyone knows
more about you because you create a
shitstorm you knew what was coming and
I'm [__] I'm a [__] because I'm
not into it but you have this has to be
said yeah you wanted to find the dead
body that was the moment for you where
you were like yes getting denominated
bonds in such a way and being
traumatized and upset because they had
our loved ones anything like that and
you [__] hope in for it you [__]
sick little [__] freak do you know
that to know MD you are in sight you've
shown your true colors to everyone now
[__]
it is over for you don't get us wrong
those brain-dead [__] who watch your
videos will forget about this in a
couple of days but anyone with a [__]
ounce of common sense will disregard you
forever now because you've proven that
inside you is nothing all it is is
emptiness and you're trying to fill that
with success and [__] but there's
nothing there and this is no matter how
many cars and houses you buy me there's
never gonna be anything because you're
so low that you would literally hope to
find a dead body so you could put it in
your thumbnail or but guess what on the
start of the video what we're gonna do
is we're gonna put a little message are
you if you're feeling a bit low go to an
emergency center because that makes
everything I'm about to do ok doesn't
month when you find a dead body you
think about that person you think about
what they've been through you think even
if you don't know them anyone will who's
got heart who is a good person or even
in all capers
we'll think about the torment and the
pain in that person must have been
through in order to take their own life
and you all you think is the [__] how
can this benefit make you [__] prick
that's all you think about you [__]
piece of [__] how can this benefit me
and it's showed we are [__] poxy
apology you put out on Twitter I seen
that on me I everything's about me I do
I get views I don't usually make
mistakes me me me
not one mention of the [__] poor
bastard who you put on the video it was
dead not one mention why is that because
it's all about you you selfish piece of
[__] [__]
honestly the start of the video spoke
volumes the way he you could see the
excitement in his eyes that I've got a
dead body on my video this has never
happened to anyone before this isn't
happening to you me that dead body
didn't happen to you death happened to
the person because they were so low and
so down think about them you [__]
wanker honestly his family how about
they do they want to say this you
[__] stupid prick
today one day
who our son brother or whatever put all
over the internet for millions of your
fans have a point or have a good giggle
what slogan be pleased found a dead body
does Marvis had a whole life behind them
it just kept on [__] circle and this
poor lad this poor dead body and it
didn't even give it any respect you know
just because that person's dead doesn't
mean they don't deserve some respect or
thought about what they would wonder how
they would feel to be part of this I get
a lot of messages from people who are
having mental problems and who are
having life problems a lot because in
doing podcasts what you give people is a
conversation to be a part of some people
are very lonely and when people are
lonely they need time to be taken up by
feeling like they're not on their own
and podcasts are really good for that
and that's why I did one-oh Christmas
Day
they're not just a [__] care about
people I care about people and it's sad
but somewhat it's sad when someone feels
like there's no other option oh that's
the best possible option this is death
you know and for someone that it's so
lightly that upset us because I get a
lot of messages from the Malloy
diffusion the young man in particular
who feel it this way then I care I care
about them and I just hope not offend
anyone out there feels like that please
police talked to someone about it and
don't want leave yourself feeling like
that's the only option because I felt
that way before
and I really have and I've never told
about this before I knew I felt like
that before and my life has gotten so
much better from when I was in that
place that because of who you love
the search is taught to someone if
you're feeling that way all right all
right I didn't expect the foot and get
upset on this video I was just wanting
to blast this cut
I'm sorry if I get an emotional I know I
don't normally do that when I think of
how many Bloods have messaged me it
really just gets to his you know thumbs
up very much everyone and I really do
appreciate people who support me up
there